[Music]
in Romania the mutashabiha penultimate
historian le they are the Taoism ting is
one of the millions of toys and workers
affected by lockdown measures in recent
months hoteliers and transport workers
are counting on the upcoming holiday
season to put their businesses back on
track while some travelers are hoping
for a summer break the commission has
published guidelines to gradually lift
travel restrictions and safely resume
tourism in Europe social distancing
health protocols for accommodation and
protective equipment will be key to
tourism restarting after the coup vid 19
crisis the transport and travel sectors
have already lost months of income due
to lockdown and sanitary measures the EU
is committed to support businesses and
workers through a more flexible state
aid system the coronavirus response
investment initiative and foreshore
instrument como Ned
live pretty the thermal is actor Lu
cookies she be so shocked economic
achilles could enact reckless rule about
it don't cry for his kun lizard but who
is connected illiquidity travellers who
paid for holidays cancelled due to the
lockdown and can obviously be refunded
through vouchers instead of cash helping
the already struggling travel business
avoid losing revenue Parliament has been
calling on the Commission for a sector
specific recovery plan MEP s asked for
financial help for the tourism sector as
well as increased EU level coordination
and a roadmap
in tourism
[Music]